it's another Saturday afternoon in
Victoria capital of the Seychelles for
many life in the sunny island state is
trouble-free but that wasn't always the
case just a few years ago the government
placed some bad bets on bonds soon the
former British colony was deeply in debt
in 2008 the country went bankrupt the
International Monetary Fund came to the
rescue
with the help of IMF funds the
Seychelles started making a comeback a
success story that began at the harbour
Indian Ocean tuna is the name of one of
the world's largest tuna fishing
companies it's also the biggest employer
in the Seychelles revenues rose sharply
in the year since the country's
bankruptcy that's one reason why the
country got back on its feet actually
representing 95 percent of the
manufacturing export of Seychelles and
around 4 percent to 5 percent of GDP
it's one of the best fishing grounds in
the world on an average you have 250,000
tonnes unloaded or tranship in the
Seychelles at Indian Ocean tuna
employees work in three shifts covering
the entire production chain they catch
the fish process it and can it then it's
exported to Europe following the IMF's
advice the Seychelles specialized in a
few select businesses and focused on
their strengths that strategy helped the
country out of the crisis besides
fishing tourism is the country's other
big source of revenue tourist numbers
have been growing steadily up to a
quarter million last year we don't have
mass tourism we don't have massive
hotels if you walk around Seychelles you
will have a hard time trying to find big
buildings large hotels taking hundreds
and thousands of tourists we've always
kept our numbers down tourism on a
smaller scale is a lucrative business as
can be seen on the North Island a short
boat ride off the main island of
Mahe there are 11 private villas guests
include Prince William and his wife Kate
we spent their honeymoon here it's a
thing of beauty
when you rock your land in the small
little rock in the middle of the ocean
the first thing the structure is the
crystal blue seas the white sands when
people come here the first thing that
comes about is the oscillation
it's that remoteness people love to see
that remoteness is also what people pay
for 2,000 euros per night unthinkable
for the locals
but since they benefit from the steady
stream of visitors many of them are
earning more money than they did a few
years ago so these days Victoria's main
market is a busy place filled with
people grateful that tougher times are
now behind them